I'm a big proponent of doing really
difficult things really difficult
engineering things to um
to see what kind of Technologies emerge
from that but
let me ask you this do you think U.S
government is hiding
some technology like alien spacecraft
technology
I have no information either way
and if you did you probably wouldn't
tell me but my assumptions you know how
what like what did my heart tell me my
heart tells me something's going on but
I have no evidence for that maybe that's
me wanting something to go on maybe
that's a human feeling to want to know
in my government's in control of what
some strange unknown thing is
um
what's your sense if such a thing
happened would uh
with this kind of information leak what
this kind of information be released by
the government
I mean that's the worry that you have is
because when you don't understand a
thing and it's novel you you want to
hide it so that uh some kind of enemy
doesn't get access to it and use it
against you
I wonder if that is the underlying
assumption I it's a it's the one people
always jump to that it's for the you
know to maintain secrecy of technology
and I assume that's part of it I wonder
if there's any other reasons that we
would want to not talk about it I
imagine that in such information would
have a shock to these you know social
economic system of any country if not
the world and so I wonder if perhaps
that was part of the concern as well you
know how Society can react to it maybe
we're anti-fragile enough now with
everything that's going on and with our
communication networks that
um you know why not now I don't know but
it's uh that's something I think about
as well
he had the effect on uh the mass psyche
uh of of something like this that uh
that there's another intelligence out
there
who had trouble enough to deal with a
pandemic
to have something of this scale
um basically having just an Inkling
of a phenomena that we have no
understanding of and could lead to
complete destruction of human
civilization or a flourishing of it
and what do you do what is the
bureaucracy of government do with that
yeah especially when they're the ones
holding the range of power and such a
communication would relinquish that
power essentially to some degree